so it's top of the hour here so I'm
gonna go ahead and kick off and go with
this session this is the title of this
session is threat modeling uncover
vulnerabilities without looking at code
and so my name is Chris Romeo and I am
from Raleigh North Carolina and I am the
CEO and co-founder of a company called
security journey we focus on how do we
teach developers about security in a
kind of a scalable way I've been
involved in security for 20 years at
this point I've done everything from
director events in a response to trusted
product evaluation to working as part of
a central security team at Cisco for
four five years and so if application
security is gonna be one of the things
that we focus on here if you have any
interest in in learning more about that
I'm actually do a podcast called the
application security podcast I actually
just interviewed somebody this morning
from the conference here I've been
interview somebody else this afternoon
for a future episode so I try to try to
go out and connect with people that are
doing interesting things in in the world
of application security I also
participate from the in the OWASP world
with a local chapter kind of where I
live and so threat modeling I guess what
kind of the reason that I could stand
here and talk to you about threat
modeling is I had the opportunity to
build out Cisco's threat modeling
practice within the 25,000 person
engineering team there and so a lot of
my experience comes from understanding
what threat modeling is but also how can
you use it in a way that it works with
twenty five thousand people and a much
bigger scale type of problem and so that
so that'll that'll influence some of
what I what I say today so here's what
I'm thinking about from an agenda here's
what I want to want to cover and
introduce you to so we'll start by just
talking about the what why and how of
threat modeling so when I say threat
modeling what do I mean and why do we do
it and then
I'm gonna walk you through the approach
that I teach developers how to do all
the time and throughout as I walk
through that process I'll actually show
you a sample threat model using the
style that I did I use so you can kind
of see how how it comes together in an
actual threat model
I'll talk real quick towards the end
about the available tools for threat
modeling and then we're gonna in capital
letters with an exclamation point we're
actually gonna threat model in here
before we leave this session today so I
have this rule that when I talk about
threat modeling or teach threat modeling
the maximum time I can talk is 30
minutes after that we actually have two
threat model because I feel I truly
believe there's not much more to say
after 30 minutes that the next step is
you actually have to dive in and do it
so that towards the end here at the 30
minute mark I'm gonna bring up a
something we can threat model we'll
split into a couple of groups here and
just give you a chance to actually try
this out and see how this process works
with a very simple and very insecure
solution or option so when I say threat
modeling what what do I mean here well I
think a threat modeling as something
that we can use to analyze the security
of anything okay it does not this is not
a this is not a concept that's specific
to code or development or anything else
threat modeling is something that after
you become proficient at it it becomes a
bit of a curse and I say that because
then you begin to threat model
everything that you experience okay I
have this experience all the time in the
United States we have this this
organization called the Transportation
Security Administration and they handle
all of the security at the airports and
they are not an elite force I'll put it
that way I'm trying to be nice this is
being recorded they are not who's going
to be defending the borders if any
someone tried to invade okay they're
kind of a least common denominator and
so a bit of what they do is is what we
like to refer to as security theater
it's you know Bruce and I are echoing
that term security theater is things
that look like people are doing things
to make security better so that the
general population will feel better but
in reality what they're doing is really
not
improving security a whole bunch and so
I say all that to say that I can't I
can't walk through the TSA without
threat modeling their whole process
meaning I'm looking at what they're
doing and I'm going there's a problem
there somebody could sneak something
through there
look there's they've got these little
ropes that are keeping people from
walking on the backside but everyone has
their backs face there everybody's
looking in this direction so somebody
could actually sneak behind this whole
group of people and get into the airport
and so but but bringing it back around
to the world of development threat
modeling is taking a design some some
idea that you have for a feature and
putting it under the security microscope
looking at how do we how could we pick
this apart how can we break this on
paper and so when you when I think about
developers specifically in threat
modeling so threat modeling is about
analyzing a design so it's about company
it's about documenting what we're doing
and then going through and considering
what are the different challenges from a
security perspective we could
potentially have to deal with here and
it's also about mitigating
vulnerabilities so all the threat
modeling in the world without that
mitigating vulnerabilities is just a
waste of time so and what I mean by
mitigate vulnerabilities is when we
start to threat model we'll come up with
a picture of what the features actually
doing will point out where the problems
and the threats are mitigating
vulnerabilities is where we go back and
say okay we got to change this design we
are missing something here that needs to
be adjusted so threat modeling is I like
to call it basic application security
hygiene so this is like but from my
perspective this is like brushing your
teeth it's something you got to do early
and you got to do often and it's
something you want to integrate into
your development process and I'm gonna
show you threat modeling from the way
that I teach it as a process but in the
long run I don't want threat modeling to
be a process I don't want it to require
a series of steps and have a document
that comes out of it at the end I want
threat modeling to be a habit so that
when a developer starts to design
something all of a sudden in their head
they start picking it apart with what
the potential problems are on they go we
got to fix this I couldn't do that
that's where you've reached like threat
modeling Nirvana is where you've had
like you have to develop
and they're just they're just seeing the
threats right in front of them in their
design they're fixing them before they
even have a chance for security person
to look over their shoulder and say oh
did you think about this so I think of
this from a security feedback loop
threat modeling is something that you're
never actually complete with you're
never there is no definition of done for
threat modeling because the product the
feature the subsystem whatever it is
you're working on unless you freeze it
in time and say we're never making
another change to this that's the only
way you could say threat modeling is
done if as long as you're continuing to
change the code change the design add
new features you're gonna have to
constantly be going back and looking at
the threat model to consider how does
this how is this impacted so when I
think of this security feedback loop
it's about identifying the threats first
so what are the challenges that we have
to deal with changing the design or
making those mitigations and then
evaluating the mitigations to see did we
actually fix the problem or is the prod
does the problem still exist and I think
of this as a feedback loop because we
just worst going to keep going around
this circle forever as long as we're
developing the product until we
end-of-life it so why should you care
then about threat modeling as a
developer why why should you even think
oh this is something that I should do
well what what we've found over the last
20 years or so is that the more
attention from an application security
perspective that you place on the front
end of your development process the less
security vulnerabilities that come out
towards the end or after the products
been released and that's just a simple
function of investing time upfront in
proper security discipline and practice
and finding those vulnerabilities in
your design using threat modeling
results in a lot less code that gets
written with vulnerabilities built into
it because you didn't see the design
problem that existed so it also one of
the other things that we're going to do
with threat modeling is it reduces what
we call the attack surface so the attack
surface in general
is any of the interfaces that exist
coming into your feature could be a
network port could be a command-line
interface could be it just could be data
coming from another process on the same
system all of those things are possible
ways that an attacker could send an
attack into your feature what you're
working on and so one of the things we
want to do in threat modeling is reduce
that overall attack surface and then the
final part here is threat modeling does
help us to focus our security testing
because we're already thinking about the
design and the pieces that go into it so
that we can we can focus in and say okay
we have this new feature it has a couple
of different things that we're building
that are that are that are at being
added as a part of this feature threat
modeling can help you to figure out
what's the one we should spend the most
time testing on I mean in a crazy simple
example you know a new web application
there's a couple different functions
there's user registration there is you
know displaying a RSS feed or a news
feed or something and then there's
credit card processing if I have only
can choose one of those three I'm gonna
start looking very testing very
carefully at the credit card side and if
I can choose two I'm gonna add user
registration and only I'm only gonna
look at the blog RSS feed portion if I
have additional time there so so a
threat modeling can help us to do that
prioritization okay so I'm gonna guess
most of the programmers in the room here
are C and C++ is that do we have any
Java programmers okay oh we got a few
awesome all right let's play a game
called spot the flaw okay look at this
piece of code here and it has a problem
and so go ahead and take a look at it
I'll give you about 15 seconds to
analyze it find the problem in this code
for me I really need some theme music
that plays at this point you have theme
music no sorry like a game show you know
like we're waiting for something to
happen
I can hum it but it'll be embarrassing
so I'll hold all right does anybody what
what's the flaw that we see here in this
okay all right okay so there's no input
validation happening here okay yeah what
else okay very weak typing is actually
occurring okay anything else yeah you
probably should do something better from
exception processing perspective is that
what you meant okay
all of these things are correct okay
it's a public method that could also be
be exposing all of these things are
correct there's no checking on anything
yeah could be a negative balance yes all
of these things are correct but I'm
gonna step up to an even higher level
and say where's the what there's no
authentication that's occurring in this
right I mean that's that's there are a
number of secure coding flaws if we get
down into the individual code but if we
step back and look at this as a bigger
system there's where's the
authentication that's happening it
doesn't exist here all of that to say
how would we find that problem if we
were going to use kind of traditional
application security approaches so
everybody probably knows static analysis
security tether or static applications
security testing tools that that you run
against your source code to find
problems running sass tools against this
snippet of code will find almost
everything that you guys that everybody
that the audience here threw out the
strings problem the public method the
potential for you know you know all the
different language specific things what
it won't find is it what the static
analysis tools not going to tell you
there's no authentication being done
here because that's a higher order
processing thing and static analysis
tools are just grinding out on the code
looking for patterns and things it
doesn't know that it's there's no AI
until somebody's going to
come up with some new company static
analysis AI or something where though
they're gonna think through the design
of your entire system and tell you oh
you're missing these things but for now
you need a human being to see that
there's no authentication here so you
know you could look at this from you
know static analysis in a dynamic
application security testing perspective
but it's not gonna it's not gonna point
pinpoint that there's no authentication
you could do a code review in this
process and perhaps you could detect
this that in a code review you could
find it in the pen testing process
that's gonna be the most expensive way
to find it along the way and then also
you could just have blind luck perhaps
you know who knows maybe I'll just get
lucky and you'll you'll be able to to
somebody all accidentally find the
problem so when I think of threat
modeling I still I still think of secure
development lifecycle or I still
visualize secure development lifecycle
from a waterfall kind of perspective
even though secure development lifecycle
is layered on top of agile layered on
top of DevOps it doesn't matter what
you're doing you can take these same
pieces and layer it in whatever your
methodology is but if we think about
where these where these challenge is
going to be found pen testing is gonna
find this missing authentication after
usually after release very seldom do
people do pen testing prior to some
milestone in their software development
process it's not something you're doing
every day cuz you can't afford it code
review and SAST and DAST scanning that's
happening during the development and
test kind of phases here and i know in
in faster moving methodologies develop
and test are the same they're happening
simultaneously and and I get that but
it's still yeah SAS is static
application security testing so this is
a a suite of tools that are that are
pattern matching looking at pieces of
code - is dynamic application security
testing so that's your scanning it's
it's more like a vulnerability scanner
for apps as what DAST is doing so one's
looking at code one's looking at the
running the running app and they're both
have the same goal of identifying
vulnerabilities but then threat modeling
so threat
modeling is something that we're gonna
do further up in the process here and so
coming back to that why is it gonna be
cheaper it's always gonna be cheaper to
find problems here then find problems
here and there's there's studies that
prove that and and but just common sense
tells me this is gonna be less expensive
than here because here's I may have
already sent it to customers and if I
have to send them a new version
sometimes they get angry if I do that
often and all the other good stuff so
what is this what is this kind of cost
well you know from assassin -
perspective it doesn't really matter
because they're not gonna find our
missing authentication problem code
review I don't know would you find that
missing authentication in an hour of
code review maybe would you find it in
10 100 I don't know MIT but it could be
expensive to find it pentesting 83,000
is you know about the average that you
pay an outside commercial company to
come in and do a pen test of some
application that's just the way it is
but then when I think of threat modeling
I think you can find that same problem
pretty easily in 8 hours or less doing
threat modeling and so my takeaway for
you here is what we're gonna describe
for the rest of our time is less
expensive than paying all these other
things - to be able to find it so yeah
[Music]
no no no no it's gonna be it's gonna be
one of the things that's going to that's
going to jump to the front of the stage
ya know and I'll show you we're gonna go
through an example here where we're
gonna we're gonna extend we're gonna
reverse engineer that code snippet and
go backwards and look at it in the
threat modeling process to see how we
would see have have pinpointed a missing
authentication problem so let's see so
who in the room here is an expert in
threat modeling who I should say who in
here is proficient at threat modeling
you do okay I'm gonna make an argument
here to you that everybody in this room
right now is already proficient at
threat modeling okay
stay with me here imagine this situation
where you you you open the front door
and to your house you step outside and
you've got you know you're one of your
children with you or you know a niece or
nephew or whatever you got to walk them
to school okay so you open the front
door you're standing on the front steps
and you're preparing to kind of walk
down the steps and go off there's a road
in front of your house cars are going by
it and you know pretty pretty fast rate
of speed okay so you hear that you look
up you see the cars coming really fast
you're thinking I have a small child
with me I have to protect them here you
hear a dog barking down the street just
making I wish I had a barking sound
effect I don't the the sun's beating
down it's very bright it's a very it's a
very hot day and the Sun is is very well
exposed here so from a threat modeling
perspective your threat modeling as soon
as you open the door and you reach down
and take that child's hand you said the
cars are flying by threat right if I let
go of the child's hand as I'm walking on
the sidewalk they could run out in the
street and get hit by the car threat I
just did I just threat I just identified
the threat I'm hearing the dog barking
down the street I know we got to walk
that way that's a threat maybe if the
dogs loose and running around I've got a
small trial with me I got to protect
them that's another threat the sun's
beating down on on us did we put
sunscreen on the child are they gonna
get sunburned while we're walking to the
school so my point is we all threat
model all the time but we don't we don't
force it we don't focus it back on our
development you know we don't apply it
at work but threat modeling is something
we do naturally as human beings we're
always trying to figure out what are the
challenges that we are faced with and a
lot of times you know in this example
oh that's happening you're not even
thinking about oh I'm doing a threat
model here there's a threat and what's
the mitigation for the dog and you know
but in your brain you're doing it
because you want to protect the child
and so threat modeling is just extending
this idea that we already know how to do
into the world attacks so couple of
questions that that somebody who's
pretty famous in the world of threat
modeling a guy named Adam Shostak who
used to be at Microsoft and built up
their program there
he's been doing some work in the wasp
the open web application security
project which is an open source group of
people that build out all kinds of
deliverables and things and and open
source them for for security and so he's
kind of come up with this approach
approach that he's used for the last few
years and I put it in here because I
think it's I think it's an even simpler
way than what I'm going to show you so I
just want you to be aware that if what I
show you you let go it's a little too
in-depth you can step back to this
version that Adam provides and and so he
asks these four questions so when he
sits down with a developer across the
table from he says ok what are you
building and then he sits there and
listens while they explain ok I'm doing
this and that and then he starts to take
him through a process where we where he
says ok so what can go wrong what could
break in this whatever whatever scope is
that we're looking at what could break
what could happen what could be the
results and then comes back with what
are we gonna do about it what can you
change to take away the the things that
you said we're gonna break and then
there's always the retrospective
question of did we do a good enough job
so you get to the end you look at
everything that you did and you say did
we do a good enough job what I'm going
to show you kind of the process approach
that I take is similar to that but you
can always come back to those questions
I put a link in the bottom of the slides
when they're available later that's to
the OWASP site where that project
actually lives there's a whole project
on application threat modeling that the
OWASP folks are working on so when I
think of threat modeling I break it down
into five steps and like I said I don't
want this to be the process that you
follow forever I want you to ingrain and
make this process operate inside your
brain so you don't need this picture
anymore and so the first thing is we
look at what is the scope that we're
doing a threat model of we draw a
picture we analyze that picture to
identify the threats we then decide how
are we going to mitigate or make those
threats go away and then we got to
document it in some way so when we think
about threat modeling threat modeling is
not an exact science okay there is no
equation we can't write it we can't
write a function that takes some amount
of input and spits out all the threats
that go into it because it's there's a
subjective nature to this because it's
human beings that are looking at a
particular
design and that that what threats they
identify are gonna be couched by their
experiences their background things that
they've seen other people do before and
so I just want you to know it's not an
exact science and the other thing is
when I think of threat modeling I have
to remind them myself all the time that
perfect in this case really is the enemy
of good
meaning trying to take a threat model to
the point where it's perfect is just
gonna drive you insane because they're
they're you're never gonna get to done
with the threat model like I said and so
you know getting to something has a
measurable approach and threat modeling
getting to perfection you're never gonna
get there so so just know that going in
that it's a work in progress and it's
always gonna be a work in progress as
you go so when I think about threat
modeling I start with the scope so we
have to figure out how what are we going
to threat model first are we going to
look at an individual feature or module
which is where I recommend if you're
getting started with threat modeling you
want to pick a small piece to look at
because when you start to get into you
know looking at the subsystem or service
level or or even the entire product it's
such a massive amount of interfaces and
there's so many moving pieces that you
can quickly get lost in in there's so
much detail I can't do anything with
this and that's why I recommend at least
in the beginning and I even still try
been doing this for years now I still
try to focus in on how can we threat
model this feature alone as a separate
entity and so that's that's kind of what
I recommend there the other thing you're
thinking about in scope is you're
thinking about who are the different
entities that are trying to attack this
feature this subsystem this entire
product we're thinking about the user
perspective because users can do bad
stuff to our systems and our features
anyway we're talking about the admin and
then we're also thinking about the
attacker in general what what would the
attacker be able to potentially do so
then I like to very early on I like to
figure out what is the attack surface
for whatever it is that we're scoping to
do the threat model of and when I think
of the attack surface this is you know
I'm asking myself these types of
questions does it accept network packets
does it perform administration is there
a CLI is it doing something that allows
me to configure this system
is it running as a demon is it the web
interface I was speaking Network
protocols all of these things are
interfaces a network protocol is an
interface because it's defined by an RFC
there's a series of usually commands and
data structures and things those are all
interfaces as an attacker
I can send attacks embedded in the
protocol that go inbound to your feature
and so that you have to think of what
are all the different attack surfaces
that are out there we could potentially
be dealing with them so then the next
the next step here is we need to draw a
picture and that picture is going to
include a couple of different things so
one thing is it's going to have a
process and so process is the first
describes some type of work that's
actually being done on the system we're
using so the approach that I take here
we're using data flow diagrams which
none of us have used since University
like once you graduate you never have to
use a DFT again I don't think but this
is a very simple set of DFD
things and for me it just works I like
to be able to sketch a picture that has
a little bit of structure to it about
how if what a feature does so then we
have data stores could that these could
be files could be databases anything
where that's storing information could
be memory even if you wanted to one of
the most important things when we're
drawing this picture is we have to
identify where the trust boundary is and
the trust boundary is the separation
between evil outside world and semi
trusted inside the feature I say semi
trusted because I don't ever trust
anything 100% but when we're thinking
about this how is our feature having
input interact with it you know from
from you know what whatever sending
whatever sending something inbound so
where this is where the evil attackers
are gonna live is outside the trust
boundary the really important thing
about the trust boundary is when we're
going through and doing our threat
modeling in our analysis we I always
focus on that trust anything that
crosses this trust boundary via a via
data flow this is always where I spend
the majority of my time I don't really
care that much about things that are
moving inside the system I'm gonna look
at them and assess them and see if
there's anything to be found
but I'm most interested when a data flow
crosses from the untrusted outside
Internet public world to the inside of
whatever I have and so then we also have
external entities we use those to map
things like attackers browsers things
that are outside of the control of our
system but yet we still want to be
thinking about them for the purposes of
the picture the nice thing is when we're
dealing with external entities we never
consider threats to the external entity
because we don't care it's outside of
our trust boundary it's outside of our
control even if we do care there's
nothing we can do because you can't
control an end users browser that's a
customer of yours I mean you can try but
good luck so here's an example of what I
call attributes and so the way I'd like
to make these data flow diagrams more
useful is I define attributes in two
different phases so there's functional
attributes and a functional attribute
just defines what is the thing doing and
when I drop when I do this type of
modeling on a whiteboard I mean I'll do
these this these type of notes right
embedded into the picture because the
picture is for me to think through how
the system works it's not a something
I'm going to put on display in a museum
or anything or you know for it's not a
piece of art and then also there's
there's another attribute of data so
what is the data that's actually being
passed here and so from a functional
perspective when I look at this data
flow right here functionally it's a
protocol and it's it's telnet the data
is a username and password that's being
sent back and forth across that
connection so this just helps me to to
keep all the the facts in front of me
that I'm trying to consider in the
process so here's an example of a data
flow diagram for that previous little
snippet of code that I wrote from a Java
perspective and so the fact that it's
missing authentication kind of makes me
draw the trust boundary and actually
push the collection of that information
outside of my overall trust boundary and
so because there's no authentication
there really isn't you know you could
even argue that
a limited trust boundary at that point
if there's no authentication that's
actually being performed but we'll come
back to that example here in a minute
and I'm almost at my 30 minute mark so I
got a speed-up here so we can start
threat modeling when we analyze our
threats we use a simple way of doing it
is what's called stride okay Microsoft
came up with this I've tried
I started learned how to threat model
using stride I tried to run away from it
and it drew me back in because it's
simple you don't have to especially when
you have developers who don't have
security backgrounds you can explain
okay here's the different
classifications of threats that we want
to think about spoofing this is trying
to be somebody who who you're not
tampering this is modifying or changing
the data on the as it's being sent
between two points for PDA ssin have
brain simpson fans The Simpsons yeah
maybe a little bit I mean Bart Simpson
always says I didn't do it nobody saw me
do it can't prove anything that's how I
define repeat iation like it's that's
what repeat EA ssin is it's it's saying
I didn't I didn't do it and you can't
prove it information disclosure leaking
some information that should be private
out of a out of a service denial of
service we all know what that means
elevation of privilege going from a
lower level you know someplace where I'm
a normal user can I somehow increase my
privilege to be an administrator through
some way so stride is what we're gonna
use is the foundation of kind of how we
think through these individual kind of
approaches and pictures and stuff so
from a mitigation perspective each of
these stride categories has a
compensating control so if spoofing is
the problem we need better
authentication strong authentication if
tampering is how is your is the concern
we come up with we better have something
that's doing protecting confidentiality
and encrypting the data between two
points repeat iation I mean strong
authentication and authorization can
help with repudiation we're getting into
digital signatures and and let's sign
things to prove that people that
somebody actually did something because
they provided something that only they
have information disclosure encryption
can help better app set can help you
know resilience and then better
authorization so there's the point is
it's there there's things that help us
to
protect these to provide these
mitigations there's compensating
controls that we can apply here I'm
going to come back to the two an example
here in a second so I want to get to
doing some threat modeling final step I
have in my process here is the
documentation step so with the
documentation step we would just the
point here is when you do threat
modeling you've got to capture the
results that come out of it somewhere it
may be that you're using jira and that's
where you're tracking all your issues
and so if that's the case I would say
then use JIRA don't do something
different just to do threat modeling to
make threat modeling work at scale you
have to you have to use the existing
tools that you have and plug into them
it could be as simple as putting your
results in a text file
it could be storing them as github
issues whatever you know whatever your
process calls for okay so real quick
before we start threat modeling a couple
of different approaches that you have
from a technology perspective to
actually do threat modeling but I still
think I always come back to this one if
I can get in a room with the people that
I'm trying to teach developer the
developers I'm trying to teach I don't
care about any of this other stuff well
I'd rather be at a whiteboard and what I
usually do is I walk in and I say draw
me a picture of what you're working on
right now and they start to draw that
picture and then I just start to ask
questions what about this what if
somebody did this what would happen in
that feature and sometimes I know the
answer to the question sometimes I don't
sometimes just throw out random
questions to see how the system works
and try and learn more from that
perspective but I think that the the
whiteboard is always the whiteboard or
the napkin you know if napkin if you're
in a bar or something you don't have
access to a good whiteboard you can
always use a little napkin for for
threat modeling as well Microsoft has a
free tool if you don't if you you know
if you're okay with using something from
the Microsoft universe as part of your
process it's if you have you ever used
Visio it's like a version of Visio that
does threat modeling but it's it's
decent
we used it at Cisco for a while and
they've really made it available so you
can run it on anything they used to have
weird light
and Seng requirements for it but they
they now they've made it a standalone
application so it's it's decent it's
worth taking a look it allows you to
take this process that I just described
for you and automate not automate it but
automate the collection of the data
points along the way
Oh wasp threat dragons a brand-new
web-based project that is building a
threat modeling solution that runs you
know as an application they only can the
only concern I have recommending that
right now I love it I think it's a great
tool and a great project but it's an
it's an alpha project right now I mean
it's there there's just it's got it's
got some problems you can you could use
it if you wanted to but it needs to get
to that beta stage to really be useful
another one is a friend of mine has a
product called arias risk which is just
a it allows you to do threat modeling
with bigger groups of people and stuff
and so I just throw that in there
because you know I don't I don't work
for that company I don't know anything
to do with it but it's one that that I
recommend that people I'm working with
if they say hey we're trying to do this
at scale with 10,000 people the
Microsoft tool the whiteboard for 10,000
people the whiteboard is hard too hard
to pull off the Microsoft threat
modeling tool and threat dragon are
going to have similar scalability
problems like what do I do with the
results who's reviewing it all that and
so a tool you know like serious risk is
gonna give you a better kind of workflow
perspective all right so with that does
anybody here know the rules of threat
modeling club okay the first rule of
threat modeling club is you do talk
about threat modeling Club and the
second rule is you do talk about threat
modeling club and what should be the
eighth rule but I couldn't figure out
how to make it work in PowerPoint
without making it really long if this is
your first night at threat modeling club
you have to threat model so with that I
give you a data flow diagram and what I
want to do five minutes over my my
allotted time for talking about threat
modeling what I'd love to do here is
have us kind of split into a couple of
groups and look at this picture and
start to think through I put a copy of
stride up here for you spoofing
tampering repudiation you know all the
different piece
and yes this is a horribly insecure
example yes I get that that's on purpose
because we have a very short amount of
time to experience threat modeling and I
don't want to give you something super
hard that takes four hours to understand
an architecture of so I did this on
purpose and made it super simple with a
with a lot of problems to be found but
what I'd love to do right now is have
people kind of let's split up into let's
kind of gather in a couple of different
groups here real quick and just kind of
throw out some ideas that you see and
we'll kind of do a little rundown at the
end so is that work can we do that all
right let's go ahead and do that we got
about nine minutes left so at about the
two minute mark to go I'm gonna come
back and ask you for at least one threat
that came out of your little pot of
people as far as one that you want to
throw out to the the world here and I'm
just going to come around and listen as
people are talking so let's let's let's
go ahead and do that now please
oh the MDU P protocol stands for made up
it's made up yeah I made it up last
night and I thought it was clever at
about you know 10 o'clock at night it
was really clever almost zero
availability so be aware you'll have to
put the inner loot in on the record we
have to have like an interlude music or
something you know or you can speed it
up you know work
yeah but we've only got like five
minutes for an example so I could have
given you an example that would have
taken four hours to dig through
[Music]
so as you're thinking threats as you're
thinking through the threats think about
it in the context of and an attacker or
somebody could do something almost like
a user stories it's similar to a user
story you know an attacker could do this
but then also what's the mitigation to
that yes this is a horribly architected
solution that's that has a hundred
problems but part of threat modeling is
what's the answer
how do you fix it so when you when you
call out something also then continuing
to say okay it's it as an attacker I'd
be able to do this what's the and then
talk about what the answer is how do you
fix that in this picture and you keep it
simple that's a good one actually that's
that's a legitimate threat right there
happens with crypto too with crypto as
well people think oh I can write an
algorithm it's not that hard and then I
won't tell anybody so they won't be able
to figure it out which always works well
for nobody
[Music]
so
this is a horribly insecure example yeah
so so I do architecture 27000 yeah no
I'm just being on a phone call we're not
doing that yeah but ignites the ideas I
got about five minutes with this
audience for them to experience threat
modeling and if I make it if I give us a
kind of a medium level difficulty people
can there be like I don't see anything
I'm talking about external entity threat
something going did you rest hundred
lines are most put a threat model for
one particular system okay so if it's
full of you know risk model but that
that's the other whole architectural
level of call center and people yeah see
that's yeah I tend to play and what I'll
call the threat modeling space and when
you start talking about the risk
modeling like you're getting by duress
I'm assuming you mean like the system
admin admin has a gun to the back of
their head or use or a user here yeah so
I mean I'm doing that users using things
incorrectly yeah Mac you by mistake or
they yeah so I would I would say I
consider some of that but the duress one
from the the trying to get developers to
do this like risk and risk modeling is
more about your thinking about that
threat whereas they have to think about
kind of the average user the average
attacker and stuff yeah I think it's I
just like to watch the light bulb come
on yeah why not storing the doctor in
the first place yeah that's always a
good you can't lose it so I that's why
you stripe for my all my credit card
processing because they handle I don't
know I don't store any there's no credit
card data anywhere near they enter it in
my site and then it gets sent right to
stripe I never get to see it they have
all
pci-dss don't go now there's no reason
to hide ya gonna be careful I'm being
recorded I'll be like they'll be like
the pci-dss people attract me now why
not recommending what we do because it's
ancient I got a client right now that
they are I did some training for them
and they're looking at the list and
they're saying okay well the PCI DSS
says we have to have things like
cross-site request forgery which Oh
Hospital 10 just dropped it for 2017
because it's it's an issue there's an
industry we've kind of gotten under
control now it's built in the frameworks
it's really hard to have a new web
application with CSRF the PCI DSS people
still in there
then people have to be trained on it hmm
and it's like that's just because they
found that somebody was attacking with
known user names in credential good
credentials and they stopped them doing
this one but the IC is not your fault
Thanks reporting it yeah yeah it was
existing credentials oh I got a closing
session out okay so you know as you're
and I've been able to overhear a little
bit of kind of what's the conversation
that's been going on and all I'm trying
to do here is is just get you to
experience this for just a couple of
minutes this is what threat modeling
looks like when you do it as a developer
you get together with a couple other
people you draw a picture of a feature
you're working on and part of the magic
in this process is having multiple
people working on it at the same time
it's very difficult to threat model by
yourself and just looking at it and
because you kind of get you get stuck on
your perspective and so when you get a
group of people working together
somebody else will say something and
then you'll you'll springboard off that
idea and it'll trigger something in your
brain to go oh yeah and then you can
take it further and continue to develop
it so let me kind of land the plane here
just so we're just because we're out of
time and then we can keep talking about
threat modeling so when I think about
this you know I talked about threat
modeling it's about analyzing security
of everything that we
doing it's about preventing bugs later
in the release process I showed you that
simple process for how we can apply it
you know scope draw analyze mitigate and
document try to try to keep that as
simple as possible that's my desire just
I want to make this easy so people can
jump in and do it talked about a couple
of the tools that are available out
there and really the big takeaway is the
best way to get good at threat modeling
is to threat model just that is what it
is like it's nuts it's something I could
teach you an 8-hour class and I fall I
did was lecture you would not get
anything more out of it than what we
just talked about here because there's
only so much talk and then it comes down
to drawing pictures and getting in there
and actually working on the threat
models themselves so with that there's
my contact information if you ever want
to continue to talk about threat
modeling or anything else just let me
know and it's been a pleasure to be here
with you today and thank you for
participating in this little exercise
I'm gonna take if anybody has questions
I'm gonna take them off mic yeah sure
sure do you want to keep recording that
okay
yeah so do you have a different question
okay is it a quick one okay
[Music]
overall architecture yep so the
challenge though a challenge with that
is people get lost you get lost when you
start trying to document the entire
system and it's you're in your brand-new
to threat modeling so what happens is
you end up with this diagram and it's
got so much complexity and then you add
more to till the point where you have a
diagram that looks like this except
there's hundreds of of processes on it
and there's hundreds of data stores and
all of a sudden you're looking at it
going what am i can't do any of this ok
so maybe a smaller system would be would
be what every system though can very
easily reach hundreds of processes and
things and I don't mean just UNIX
processes this this is this is just some
some unit of work being done by some
component in the system and so that's
why I recommend start small only because
when you look at a single feature you're
not gonna get is it's not gonna be as
difficult you're not gonna get lost in
the complexity of it so yeah so if we
just kind of walk through this dock this
diagram the approach I always take is I
use this stride methodology and I just
systematically go through and consider
each one so I'm gonna start with
spoofing and say ok we've looked at the
the made up protocol both of the input
and output version we talked about it
has zero confidentiality and zero
integrity protection so that tells me
right away I've got a spoofing problem
that there's a threat of spoofing that
exists throughout this entire
architecture depending on what's going
on on the back end I may have a spoofing
problem there as well tampering is gonna
be another threat somebody an attacker
could change some some of these requests
if like we said there's no
confidentiality on these connections
then they could actually an attacker
could do a man-in-the-middle attack
where they intercept the traffic make
some changes to it and then send it back
through because there's nothing
protecting that data along the way
repeat iation as I scan through and look
at this I mean I didn't draw an admin on
to this but repudiation that the threat
that
somebody makes a change on this system
through the configuration process say if
we had an admin you know say we drew an
admin over here who was part of this and
we showed them connecting to the
configuration daemon I would ask the
developers the question so how do you
know that person actually made the
change that they said they that you
think they did how can you prove it so
if they wiped out the entire fleet of
router configurations how do you know
who that was and so that's that's one
it's a threat but it's gonna take more
questioning to get to the - how does the
system do it information disclosure I
mean so we have to we have to talk in
more depth about what what's actually
exposed here at this interface is there
a daemon that's providing some amount of
information
I didn't say whether there was authentic
a ssin here I left it up to you to
decide in your own little model in your
mind if there was authentication
happening same things happening here on
the backside we have to think about we
have to ask the question what's
occurring at this daemon what did what
is this thing giving off what
information is it giving off without
authentication
what's it giving off if we are
authenticated I look at this and I say
okay this is a denial of service waiting
to happen because there's nothing that
says we have any type of protections
that's going to prevent a denial of
service condition from occurring in this
platform and then elevation of privilege
let's pretend we have well I mean those
so we have the config daemon so there is
a threat that an attacker you know we
haven't really described whether this is
public Internet or whether this is some
type of control network where we're
we're hidden inside the data center but
so we have to consider the potential
threat of elevation of privilege
happening here we have to ask the
developer the question well how is
authentication happening from this
router to here or here to here how do
they know they're talking to each other
is there a user account that has a
privilege associated with it and then is
there a corresponding admin privilege
level that goes with it that somebody
could try to do something inside the
daemon in how they interacted with it to
try to raise their privilege so my
process is always gonna fall back to
stride as how I start and then once we
get through stride if everything looks
if I can't find anything in stride
then I'm gonna pull back and say okay
now let's start brainstorming new stuff
that's an outside of that methodology
but what I find is when I'm starting off
with new projects and helping people
threat model there's so much that
there's so many things that get
triggered in the stride
alone that that takes them six months to
fix the problems that we can find here
and then after that the next stage is to
if everything here is checked where
we're like we got all this stuff figured
out then we start looking at the diagram
and saying okay how can we be creative
from an attackers perspective and take
it to a whole other level of you know
yeah I mean there's just there's a we
have to we have to have more detail and
we have to have the basics kind of
figured out first before we continue on
so that that's my take on on what it on
what I see in that picture or what I was
intending for you to see or hoping you
know kind of so you saw some of those
things along the way so anybody have any
questions I know where this is it
lunchtime right now okay I hate to stand
in the way of anyone's lunch so yeah
thank you